ha sido el ministro de exteriores iraní
mohammad javad sheriff quien ha estado a
la delantera responder los últimos
movimientos relacionados con el acuerdo
nuclear con irán dados tanto en
washington como las capitales europeas
en las últimas horas esto lo ha hecho a
través de varios trinos el último se
refirió al movimiento dado por el
gobierno estadounidense joe biden de
retirar esa petición hecha por el
gobierno anterior de donald trump ver e
imponer nuevas sanciones contra irán en
el marco del consejo de seguridad de las
naciones unidas aludiendo a un mecanismo
conocido como el snap back en la
resolución 22 31 que irán en su momento
había dicho que no era que no tenía
ninguna validez
sharif le dio la bienvenida pero dijo
que irán no volverá a cumplir cuando
firmado en el acuerdo hasta que eeuu
vuelva o quite todas estas sanciones
económicas que ha impuesto sobre irán
desde 2018 esto se da en un momento en
el cual la preocupación sobre el futuro
del acuerdo aumenta pues el próximo
martes se prohibirá el acceso relámpago
de los inspectores de la organización de
energía atómica a ésta
plantas nucleares lo que ha hecho que el
movimiento diplomático a nivel mundial
sea aún mayor para tratar salvar este
acuerdo